Film Courage: How do you raise money for a movie?
RamfisMyrthil, Film Producer, Film Consultant
and Speaker:That's a good question.
Every project has been different, have put it
together and figured it out. It's been various
ways sometimes, it's been grant money from for
example SF film does grants and they give a lot
of money away to projects that warrant the money.
I go to SF film or try back a Film Institute,
well TFI is not here anymore but in the past I
have as well as Sundance as various labs. There's
other festivals as well that have some type of lab
or dynamic to be able to do that. But outside of
that I go to places where I can find money. One
of the ways I raise money on a project at least
in Long Island there's country clubs everywhere
and in the summer their golf tournaments and in
New Jersey too and Upstate Westchester, so I
go to events where there's people that have
that type of money so I've gone to a
golf tournament. I was at the table
getting like my salsa, water with lemon and
lime as usual and this guy came up to me and
he's like Oh what do you do, what's
your story? He's a very interesting guy,
not in film. He's kind of like a startup guy and
he's been in some really great ventures and made
good money and I told him like what I do and why
I was there and he's like well I know someone that
you should talk to and that was it so I followed
up with him put me in touch with this guy and
I set up a meeting with this guy and I
still to this day don't know if he's a CPA
or if he's a tax attorney I still don't know
and I pretty much went in and I met with
him and I told him what I do and I'm like I'm
assuming that he has clientele or clients that
have access to money that can invest because that
was always the thing I would did I look for CPAs
or lawyers that have a lot of clientele on that
level that have that kind of income because they
maybe need to lose money or they need to have
write-offs or or maybe they'll be open to that
Venture so he looked at me and said I don't
have anyone like that and I'm like why are we
even here how did this meet even get set up he
didn't even know what the meeting was about I
didn't even know who he was and he's like well
I invested in some plays and I've done a movie
or two and I'm like oh you're the guy and he's
like yeah so I'm like I should be pitching you
then should I pitch them and it's like all right
send me all the paperwork and everything I look
at it so I followed up with him and then like
a month later met up with him again this time I
came with my team at the time I had representation
I came with my manager and the let him know that
we're like legit we're not going to take the money
and run to Aruba and he was like okay all right
send me more paperwork and let me think about
it sent the paperwork again followed up with
him a month later like he said he didn't read
it he hasn't looked at he hasn't had the time
he's very busy I get it especially dealing with
people's taxes or if he's a tax attorney whatever
and then ultimately I went in that third
time just one-on-one with him and pitched him
and he cut me to check just like that
so does it always happen like that no
and even till this day he calls and checks in
on me like hey he wants to I was a member at
the Friars Clubs I'd bring him there the Friars
Club is a prestigious private club in New York
where Frank Sinatra The Rat Pack they were
all members they're the ones that started
the comedy roast so I was a member there for
many years and while being there I would bring
an entertain potential financiers and the owner
of the Minnesota Vikings is a member I remember
going in one night and I'm a curious person to
ask questions and I saw that one of the rooms
that's never really like booked up for private
events was closed and it was our Thursday night
Cabaret night and I asked like one of the waiters
that worked there like what's going on why is the
room closed oh this guy's celebrating he
sold his company I'm like oh that's cool
how much did you sell his company for sold it for
980 million I'm like whoah who is this guy I need
to meet him and everything is private in a private
club so people don't really want their business
being known so I said listen give me the intel, I
won't say your name I'll just say I found out so
I waited for this thing to end and then I
approached this guy and I said congratulations and
he doesn't know who the hell I am congratulating
him he's probably like I'm like yeah man they call
him the wolf like he was slick this guy he's like
I became a billionaire selling his company and he
was well off before he sold the company so I'm
congratulating him and telling him how proud I
am of him and it's amazing and I know he probably
had this whole story and he said like what the
hell is this guy talking about who is he and then
we just stayed in touch and I'd see him at various
events once in a blue and he always just told
me like like when the time is right if there
was something that made sense to approach him I
never did approach him there wasn't something I
felt because I don't I feel that you have one shot
sometimes especially with a billionaire so I want
to make sure it's something that's a no-brainer
It lines up I mean this guy is screaming A-list
so the project is not going to be something with
an ensembled cast of working actors in television
this is probably going to be with Brad Pitt like
then he's going to pay attention he's that kind
of guy so being in a private club has helped a
lot like the the Friars Club I've met so many
financiers or potential financiers and people
introduce me or it doesn't even have to be the
Friars Club it could be Soul house or Norwood
which is another private club on 14th Street
in Manhattan or the core club which is super
expensive I think it's like 50 grand to apply
for the application and then $15,000 every year
so with the Friars Club it was it was expensive
not as expensive as a court Club but that was
one way I found a lot of potential financiers
and people that are willing dealing that like
entertainment because it's an entertainment club
and then going to Polo matches to have a horse
is it's not like in the early back in the day
where everyone had a horse and it was cheap and
having a car was expensive it's the other way
around now if you have a horse have a good horse
a horse that does polos at least like a million
dollars or something to feed it right to maintain
it have a ranch it could run around so I go to
Bethpage Polo it's in Long Island and they also
do in the Hamptons in Long Island too and I go to
these matches and I'll just go and I look at the
calendar sometimes they have an event with Ferrari
all right if they can afford a Ferrari they have
a horse they can definitely cut a check so I go
in and I just start talking to these people I
introduce them and the thing is that most of
these people they started from something or maybe
they were born into a family with money but they
respect the hustle so straight to the point make
sure my eyes are dotted tease across who I am why
I'm there and like oh that's so interesting and
it can add it to my collection or something so
did I successfully close any investors at Polo
matches no but I did build a Rolodex of people
that were open and interested and the things that
you need one yes you don't need a bunch of yeses
that's all you need so and and one door may open
up to another door I made a promise to myself to
go to Art basil every year a cashing director
I work with was in with these guys from RBC the
Royal Bank of Canada I went to some really boring
event that they threw together at the Harvard Club
in Manhattan and it was very stuffy Wall Street
types and I actually fell asleep a couple of times
it was like a nine hour intense day talking about
things that I felt they were talking hieroglyphics
and reciprocals and I just didn't understand I
understood some of it but I couldn't weigh in but
at the end of the day I became friendly with the
guys from RBC they kept talking about art baths
I'm like what is this art basil thing I don't even
know what it is and I felt a little embarrassed
because everyone else knew and there were a lot
of people in the art world that were there or
collectors so the RBC guy said we're going to Art
battles with the end of the year this was maybe
in this late spring or summer so I said hey I want
to come and they said okay great we'd love to have
you down there you just got to make your way down
there so before I Dazzle I reconnected with RBC
guys and I stayed in touch with them throughout
developed a relationship with one of the financial
advisors over there and I'd invited him to
the Friars Club and he loved it and geeked out
and I was looking for ways to help him as
well so on a one-way street it's give and
take give and take it wasn't hey just get me
to Art basil it's like how can I help your
business or clients and he appreciated
that because most people don't ask that
so I went down to Art basil and I went to the
first night they threw this event at the Versace
Mansion in Miami and it was just incredible
it was spectacular I mean they were it got so
busy they were turning away billionaires at the
door that's how crazy it was and from that point
on I'm like I need to be there not just I need
to be there I need to go down there with these
guys because the guys that are coming with them
are ball players or ex-ball players clients that
have Fu money and really Deep Pockets hedge funds
Venture capitalists people with billion dollar
funds and maybe they're not the right person to
fund it but they know someone that potentially
can so I made it a point to go to Art basil
every year except for the year of the pandemic
because it didn't happen and I've developed like a
investor like list and people that are interested
and the reality of it is that because I've been to
so many of these events I used to have a database
with all the investors listed this is a hard
lesson learned one of my interns had shared it
through his personal email and I sort of loaded
it to our transferred it to my Google account but
I think his account deleted and then I lost the
whole spreadsheet so I've I've told myself one of
these days I'm going to build the investor
spreadsheet again but I just haven't had a
chance to go through it but the reality of it is
that I have like a Rolodex of investors and I've
forgotten their mandates because they all have
different things like come to me if a project
needs finishing money or come to me when the
project is earlier on or come to me if it's like
a huge star or come to me if it's like a million
dollar movie or a 20 million dollar movie so going
to all these events along the way I've built like
a Rolodex of people I can go to or and the reality
of it like I said same thing with actors you hot
you hire them ask them about their friends you
get one investor you get their friends and I've
done that multiple times when I do a project like
do you have friends and their friends come in and
put money in so that's how I found private Equity
just going to maybe like a dentist convention
I used to be the way that people always said
is finding investors go to dentists and doctors
one of my dear friends that's what he does all
his investors are dentists and doctors he goes to
these doctor convention centers and he meets them
so I haven't quite done that I will if I have to
but I've gone to other convention centers I was at
this big thing actually here in Los Angeles
it was like a a cell phone convention and
and it was the last day I was there and I and I
met this guy he was a guy from the Middle East
that was between Miami and the UAE and I told him
what I did and he was like wow that's interesting
I've always wanted to get into the movie business
and monetize my money so then he approached
me about investing I had gone down to Miami a
couple times to meet with him and his brother
and I built this model I'm not exercising it right
now but it's basically lasting last in first out
and lifo last in first out that's the term and
he was really interested in this model and how
it works is if it's available if the film is
set up if it's not pair of pursue this investor
could come in last when the film gets sold they
get paid out first like if the film is almost
finished with production or it's finished with
production and he really liked that model and
that's what he wanted to do and the problem is
that I did find some films that did have that but
he wanted a quick return so I couldn't guarantee
a quick return and I just told him that when I
have a project where a return can be quick
then I can Bridge you in and bring you in
but yeah it was just right place right time
sharing that story with this individual
but now when I build out projects I'm also
thinking about what production company or what
maybe distributor I could maybe partner up with
finance it and release it that's been my my
strategy now going forward and I'm not going to
do that on every movie but I was just in the UK
for example and I met with this writer director
and he just did this movie I did really well he's
on a series now and I met with two financiers
while I was out in the UK that I met at can
well one of them I met a can the other one I met
virtually but they go to can all the time and
the first group I met with they'd already know
me they liked my work we want to find something
together they were familiar with the director
I was going to meet with and they want to work
with him too the second group I met with they have
three companies one is a sales company that helps
find financing the other one finances against
debt meaning tax credits or any type of debt
and the third one is more of an equity company
so I'd mentioned this filmmaker they were very
familiar with them and they want to work with me
too so going into that meeting I already liked
the director like his work well I don't know if
I like him yet I know I like what I've read so
far so when I met with him we spent two or three
hours and really bonded together and I told them
about the groups I met with and that they know
him and he's like I know them too and that's
great so now potentially we have financing the
finance whatever we want to do together and then
he told me about the two groups that financed his
last shown and he told me about an overall deal
that he has he told me to speak with his agent
to clarify it his agent had introduced us
so ultimately we don't have a project yet but
I like him he's Cuban-American from Miami I'm
Haitian-aAmerican I lived in Miami for a little
bit we have that connection we like each other
like each other's work he watched my film the same
day and he's like I wanna I love what you did I
don't know how you created it I want to work with
you and and I liked his work so now we ultimately
are going to find something to work on together
we figured out the financing and we just have to
figure out the distribution that works properly
with this so that's one example of me figuring
out the financing before we even shoot can I
ask you something real quick sorry what does
it mean to respect the hustle you said with some
of these individuals these these high net worth
individuals you'll meet them and they respect the
hustle what is that mean most people over promise
them to deliver so I'll give you a perfect example
of where it completely flipped I went to Sonoma
Film Festival I want to say it was maybe 2017
first time I had the film that I did with Miss
Shady's rule there and how Sonoma works is that
if you have a feature at least back then I don't
know how it is now if you have a feature they put
you up in a hotel if you have a short then they
pair you up with a housemate or something like a
family that wants to go to the festival and this
is their way of volunteering and the homes in
Sonoma are very nice so I paired up with this
family that was really amazing and they stayed
in touch with me and I stayed in touch with them
after and what ended up happening is that the the
woman of the household had sent me a text one day
about this guy named Gary Nelson and I opened up
this link read about him and he has an HR company
that's been very successful and he wanted to get
involved in film he went to finance movies and
he wanted to make the kind of films that I was
making and he had some other other things that
he wanted to add and he really loved Sonoma and
his like his town in his City and and humankind
so she didn't tell me to contact him she was just
sharing found it interesting I took it as like
I need to call this guy so I found his HR number
called asked to speak to him asked who I am I said
I'm a filmmaker I read this article I want to work
with Gary Nelson oh okay all right well you're not
going to get his number I'll give you his email
you can email him and if he wants to engage
he'll he'll engage with you so right after I wrote
a very detailed email sharing about my experience
in Sonoma I love Sonoma and that I read about his
mandate and how I'm making the type of films that
he wants to finance and that I'd love to work with
him and he emailed me back within five minutes
sent me his number we jumped on a call and I told
him I'm gonna come out there one day and meet
with you and shake your hand so I'm serious and I
want to work with you and you said okay all right
great he probably hears it all the time so what
had happened was that I think I told you after
Sundance I go to LA for about a month and that's
what happened the following year I went to LA
and the bay is only a 45 minute plane ride
from LA from LAX so I booked a one-way
up there I called Gary I said Gary guess what I'm
coming to Sonoma to meet you and he was like what
like yeah so I took a sprinter bus and and this
stupid Mark Twain quote I kept hearing because
this was was it was it in the summer no no it
wasn't in the summer that happened another time
when I went to see Gary but Mark Twain has this
thing where he says the coldest winter I ever had
was a a summer in San Francisco and I'd gone in
a T-shirt and I was like freezing cold and know
that it was cold in San Francisco that time of
the year so anyway I jumped on a sprinter bus it
takes about an hour to get into Sonoma County
got into Sonoma County and then I jumped in a
45 minute Uber and drove to Gary met him how did
you get here you have no car oh I took Uber and
then he told me by the way I am an investor in
Lyft if you don't mind take Lyfts so now usually
I take Lyft if I'm in the US if I'm outside of
the Country lift doesn't exist I take an Uber
and then I basically did exactly what I told
Gary I was going to do like he saw that I took
a plane I took a bus took a Uber just to sit
down with him I didn't ask for anything and
he bought me breakfast it was very nice of him and
we had a really good meeting we spent like almost
two hours together and it went from me pitching
him to him telling me about the projects that
he's wanting to make and do I want to be a part of
it and there was a project that he wanted to tell
and I got on it right away it was a lot
of prolific singer from the 70s or 80s and
I was saying like Gary we need to move on a quick
Gary doesn't move his that move as fast as I do
but what ended up happening was that there was
an announcement in the trades that the story was
snatched up and it didn't happen so because of
that but so meeting the hustle is I mean this is
I'm not saying that this is the only way to
do it I mean this is probably I feel like
I over delivered and under-promised that's what
I did in terms of that like granted I said that's
what I would do but most people aren't going to do
that like if it's someone that's serious NFL next
flight out I will go anywhere in the world Abu
Dhabi Dubai if I have to learn a couple of words
whatever I need to do I'll go there it has to be
someone very serious and multiple comments I'm not
going to just go because it's a big investment in
time and money but I want people to treat me very
serious and know that I'm no joke I expect them
to cut a check if I'm going to do all of that if
it fits within what they would their mandate or
whatever how they invest I'll make sure that I
tee it up to make sure that everything is in top T
shape and that's what I mean like meet the hustle
because most people aren't going to do that it's
exceptional or rare so they know that I am going
to take care of their asset I'm not going to take
their money and run around the world and just live
my life I'm going to take their money and do my
best to get them a return at least break even
and communicate with them and let them know and
if I mess up let them know too because there's
no guarantees in this business there's things can
there's a acts of nature that could affect things
what would make a doctor dentist lawyer someone
who's a CPA invest in an independent film
a lot of time is Vanity like oh cool my name is
on this project like I'm an executive producer
most of the time when they're doing that there's
this rumor it's kind of true is that even though
these guys are brilliant they're not good
with their money they put their money into
stupid things so a lot of times at least a
doctor a lawyer will be a little bit smarter
but doctors and dentists specifically they do it
all the time they buy things that they don't need
so that's why they're a great Target in
terms of that and why they've invested so
many times lawyers more or less maybe they'll
bring in a client or maybe they'll put in
but same kind of deal like I remember being at
Sundance and I went to this party and I don't
think anything happens by accident if I ended
up at this party didn't know much about it and
the party or event most of the people there
were all investors had no idea I just went
and the young lady I spoke with majority of the
time see what was a lawyer that invest in film
and she represents 50 people that invest so again
they have links to it or a lot of times maybe they
want to help save change the world or they want
to do some type of impact yeah or or it's just
exciting to go to a screening go to a festival
maybe their work is so cut and dry or something
that's not as I know it seems sexy and fun to
be a part of filming it's a lot sometimes what
they'll do is that they'll bring a their client
to set oh like look I invest in movies that's
what I do it's vanity like oh wow so sometimes
it's that so it's a multiple bit of things.